it would be inspiring for people to know
a lot of artists actors writers struggle
but you were really living on the edge
for a while when you were starting out
meaning more or less squatting in places
to kind of because you didn't
necessarily couldn't make rent is that
true yeah I mean I squatted for about
um
I was about three and a half years
um good God but you know it might have
been longer I think I was in one place
three and a half years and then I sort
of squatted in a few other areas around
London so it was probably a bit longer
than that but it was a bit of a
lifestyle thing as well you know I mean
I I I I had a job and you know I just
wasn't
um you know clearly I wasn't I wasn't in
in the industry at that point I was
working in in Kilburn actually the most
Irish place in London that I could
possibly find and and I was working in a
job surgery so I didn't earn very much
but I definitely aren't enough for rent
it was it was kind of a
I think it was a bit of a Bohemian
Choice like I arrived arrived in London
with um like 90 quid
so I I couldn't afford rent when I came
over first but then you know I got a job
and but at that point I was you know
just part of this
um
this sort of yeah lifestyle uh I guess
loads of Irish people and you would sort
of there was a lot of um we we lived in
a high-rise flat and we occupied a a an
apartment
on the on the 18th floor that was
furnished with
um stuff that we found on the street
you know
um it was just it was kind of fun I mean
the the the when I stopped doing it like
I I squatted this sort of um disused
um shop in in Camden and and we got like
you know the Heavies came round because
really it was it was legal at the time
as long as you got into the
um the building and you didn't cause any
damage or if you did you know if you it
wasn't a big deal it wasn't a big deal
you had like squatters rights
um but then if you squatted a property
that was private and
um you know the landlord knew a few Lads
with baseball bats then it wasn't
um great so that that's what happened
they kind of like rushed rushed us
please tell me you're staying at a hotel
here in New York I love the idea that
you would win the bafta give a speech
leave the the theater the theater or the
auditorium with the with all the flash
bulbs and the cheers and good and then
we'll go out to an alley and lie down
old habits die hard I have a home now
and yeah oh I just want to determine
that that's good I just was worried
about you okay I do worry
you're such a
and I'll use the word impeccable I think
your writing is impeccable you're such a
great terrific writer and uh I know I
started as a writer and struggled with
this transition into
um
performing it's new I knew it's what I
wanted to do but had trouble figuring
out what's my path right you said that
initially you thought of yourself as
someone who would be in front of the
camera but at what point do you realize
I'm I'm I can write I'm a this is I have
a superpower here God I don't know like
really really recently because I think
um I I really do think if you start out
as a performer you sort of
see you continue to see yourself as that
and uh you feel a bit cheeky calling
yourself a writer
um so you'd be like I'm an actor and I
do a bit of writing and because I
um
you know because it was something I sort
of learned on on the job you know and I
had a lot of great
um people along the way who who you know
taught me
um
um how to be better
um I felt like I was kind of
you know I kind of felt it was down to
them and I kind of felt like if I if I
was sort of
um just Cast Away on my own I I wouldn't
be able to do it like I just sort of
built this thing in my head and and so I
really just had to start
um
you know
um I really just had to start doing it
on my own before I even remotely
considered myself to be a writer and
and then I just had to build up
confidence with that and and do it a few
times and and then realize that you know
that the shows I make you know the
people like them and it's not a fluke if
I go you know you just can convince
yourself it was a fluke we said your
initial show you have the success
um and then it's not followed up right
away is that right oh yeah with pulling
it's just yeah it was it was which maybe
rattles the confidence a little bit was
that was that just a one-off was that
just all I had in the tank I absolutely
thought that was
um that was a one-off and and I got
really really lucky with pulling because
um I mean I started in sketch comedy and
um you know there was kind of a team of
us and and I really enjoyed that but
then once I started writing sitcom once
I started writing characters and
narrative I thought well no this is
everything this is all I want to do now
yeah and but I got really lucky with
with Dennis we were we were really close
friends at the time anyway and we both
had these really similar life experience
and and and and sort of Take On The
World and
um for Dennis's
you know Dennis is probably a Bonafide
genius and
um and I kind of relied on him quite a
lot you know Dennis Kelly Dennis Kelly
who who wrote Matilda the Musical and
Utopia and
um yeah he's a brilliant thing yeah he's
absolutely brilliant and um
so
well and and you know we we couldn't
have done it without each other but
right I did feel like
I relied on him very heavily and uh and
then you know we parted ways because we
were we were
um you know he didn't want to be just
writing for me for the rest of his life
right he had stuff to do and um so I I
started out
um you know just trying to go it alone
and uh
so you know you I wrote loads of
um pilots and
um yeah you know just got on this
um just got on this conveyor belt of
making part over here like in in La like
so oh well I've I've made my fortune
over here and
and there was this thing that I'd never
experienced in the UK of of of it being
like a success to to get to get a pilot
to make a pilot and you know that whole
thing of you
you know everyone gets on the phone and
they tell you they're gonna pick up your
Pilots everyone loves it yeah and then
and then you know it doesn't get made
into anything but that's not considered
failing really like you you come over
the next year and you have another girl
and you've got another pilot and
everyone's like hey and whereas I just
felt like I was kind of going around in
circles for I mean five years at least
just uh and also I had this thing where
I was kind of making Pilots that were
ending up as something that I didn't
even if they got picked up I would have
been like I don't want to make that yeah
you know because it changes you get your
notes you get to change things a little
bit and then especially if you're if
you're new if you're a bit of a rookie
you're kind of going you know they do
that thing where they say um
um well if you make this change it's
just it's just for the sales tool it's
just you know we'll make this change
we'll add the voice over it won't be
like that in the series we'll just add a
voiceover across the whole thing right
and um and then in series we you know
and so you kind of get you kind of get
um
caught up in that a bit and you make all
these changes and you end up with
something that isn't remotely like you
know the thing you sort of hoped it
would be